- [Instructor] We are told
researchers scored 31 athletes
on an agility test.
Here are their scores.
It's in this histogram.
And what I'm going to ask you is,
which of these intervals,
interval A, B, or C,
which one contains the
median of the scores,
and which one, or give an
estimate which one contains
the mean of the scores.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
So let's just start with the median.
Remember, the median you could
view as the middle number,
or if you have an even
number of data points,
it would be the average of the middle two.
Here we have an odd number of data points,
so it would be the middle number.
So what would be the middle number
if you were to order them
from least to greatest?
Well, it would be the one
that has 15 on either side,
so it would be the 16th data point.
16th data point.
And so we could just think
about which interval here
contains the 16th data point.
You could view it for
the 16th from the highest
or the 16th from the lowest.
It is the middle one.
All right, so let's
start from the highest.
So this interval C contains
the 13 highest data points
and then interval B goes
from the 14th highest
all the way to the 18th highest.
So this B contains the median.
It contains the 16th highest data point,
or if you started from the left,
it would also be the
16th lowest data point.
So that's where the median is.
The median.
Now what about an estimate for the mean?
Well, you have calculated
the mean in the past,
but when you're looking at
a distribution like this,
when you're looking at a histogram,
one way to think about the mean is
it would be the balancing point.
If you imagine that this
histogram was made out of
some material of, let's
say, uniform density,
where would you put a fulcrum
in order to balance it?
If you put the fulcrum right over here,
it feels like you would
tip over to the left
because this is a
left-skewed distribution.
You have this long tail to the left.
If you really wanted to balance it out,
it seems like you would
have to move your fulcrum
in that direction of that left skew,
in the direction of the tail.
And so I would estimate to balance it out,
it would actually be closer to that,
which would be interval A.
Interval A would contain the mean.
The intention of this type of exercise
isn't for you to try to
calculate every data point,
in fact, they don't give you
all of the information here,
and add them all up and then divide by 31.
It's really to estimate and
to also get the intuition
that when you have a left-skewed
distribution like this,
you will often see a
situation where your mean
is to the left of the median.
If you have a right-skewed distribution,
it would be the other way around.
And as we will see, when we
see a symmetric distribution,
the mean and the median will
be awfully close to each other,
or when you have a roughly
symmetric distribution.
If you have a perfectly
symmetric distribution,
they might be exactly in the same place.
So let's do another example.
So here it says we have
the ages of 14 coworkers,
and I want you to do is say
roughly where is the mean
and roughly where is the median?
Is it roughly at A, is it roughly at B,
or its it roughly at C?
Pause this video and try to figure it out.
So let's first start off with the median.
We have 14 data points.
So this would be the average
of the middle two data points.
It would be the average of the seventh
and eighth data point.
Well, you could say one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
and then the eighth one is here.
So the seventh data point is a 30.
The eighth one is in the 31 bucket.
So the average of the
two would get you to B.
Another way that you
could think about it is
you can just eyeball it and see you have
just as many data points below B
as you do have above B,
and so that also gives you
a good indication that B
would be where the median is.
So that is where the median is.
Now what about the mean?
Well, this is a perfectly
symmetric distribution.
If I wanted to balance it,
I would put the fulcrum
right in the middle.
So I would say that the mean would also,
the mean would also be
at B, and we are done.